when we saw the scene of you two at the
wedding you said that you could not kiss
her
yes okay have you guys ever kissed
before that
yes you have yeah are you intimate
before that yes you have okay so you've
kind of
consummated the relationship a little
context
basically this is a clip from 90 day
fiance essentially the woman
is american she met this guy online i
believe he's from tunisia
they get married he comes over and then
they start having some problems
he's in the process of getting his green
card set up through the marriage process
was there any intimacy after the wedding
at all after the well yes
there was but we started facing a
problem
what is what was the problem i don't
want to say like this is very private
instead of taking care of that problem
she was like fighting with me over it
this is something that no man in the
world can accept that
and then and then she was
like be like
sitting on the floor crying screaming in
front of her teenagers
i want my sex tonight if you don't give
me my
tonight i will i will i will
call the immigration i will get you
deported
i've heard that are you serious
are you serious i've heard that so many
times
being in bars
all right let's get it all right so this
guy was wearing the pros and cons am i
going to tell these stories or not
yeah okay let me just do it yeah so pink
game all right
listen we're in this province right a
lot of girls go to cuba
and they go get some man here
in montreal there's a lot of cuban
nights where like there's cuban band
dancing it's
like that and going on and stuff like
that right
so when you get these gentlemen here
they want to be with their people and
that's normal the cubans want to be with
the cubs yeah cause they want to you
know they want to you know they want to
reminisce that's just normal
right because they left cuba to go to
montreal and be with the ladies okay so
you want to hear your music and stuff
like that
reminisce so in the bars where there's
special like cuban lights and stuff like
that
too many women too many women talking
about
being not happy with a certain situation
and when the guy comes back threatening
the guy to you know i'mma call
immigration give me an example
of what conversation like you might have
heard oh okay you're just gonna act like
that you're just gonna act like i'm
gonna be like that and everywhere like
if i tell you to come there
you're like you're with me you don't
dance with other people what you want me
to call immigration on you
you have to respect me like i'm the one
that brought you here
and i'm i'm in charge of your paper so
you have to i've heard that
way too many times
through the course of me going out in
clubs how is that
not predatory we always talk about
there's power dynamics
with a manager and an employee how is
this any different
in fact here the consequences aren't
just you're going to lose whatever job
up to the consequences are you're going
to be sent back to a living situation
that's way worse than what you are right
now as far as i'm concerned
women like this are monsters it's not
just cuba it's dominican republic all
those little
islands where there's uh tourism and i'm
pretty sure it's the opposite as well
for other countries
it's not a physical leash it's a mental
leash that they have it's an
institutional leech that they have i
have institutional power to have you
removed from this country
and remove any opportunities that you
have i've heard that that's brutal yeah
absolutely brutal so when i'm watching
this clip and i see it i'm like how are
the comments but we don't know if it's
real
we don't know but i haven't watched this
i don't know what that no no this guy's
died live this is a real show oh no no
i'm not saying if it's a real short not
it's a real situation what's what's her
rebuttal today
okay is he lying is he not lying what's
going on because that's just what he
said
that's his side of the story all right
so inside the story is that i want to
see i want to see the rest of it
danielle can you tell us what he's
talking about he has told people that i
smell
and i do dawn maybe curls really
speaking
he didn't know about no that's p no it's
not just me to pull up for you
go ahead go ahead all right i'll put up
myself because it's not there is
elements in that is in there
there you go there's the whole bunch
article proved that female is just
blah blah blah there's other stuff in
there but there is
yeah that's what i said no no no no no
it's not just elements of it there is p
in there it's mixed with us that is
exactly what the [ __ ] i said no you said
there's elements of
there is elements in
that is in there if i give you water
yeah
okay and i put in the water yeah just
because it's mixed doesn't mean it's not
pee in there i understand what you're
saying
okay so you gotta put on if i put p in
there and i throw it in your face
are you gonna tell me it's not my [ __ ]
no i'm gonna punch you in your face and
you said i did that because that's not a
woman
so woman does that she throws in your
face it's not pee it depends
it's me don't you don't keep seeing me
no no i see i move hey listen listen
i'm not mad if people are into it but
let's be honest about what it is and it
is what it is it's okay
but it is there's be in it but it's not
just that
sure but it's a huge quantity of it so
you got put on
let's be real sure if you're okay with
it you're okay with it i'm not judging
people but i hate when people say
it's not no boo boo there's a huge
amount of it yeah it's really
chicken curry it's not chicken yeah it's
elements of curry
it's chicken though the whole smell
thing
i get that yo there's gonna be girls
that are gonna be in the comments being
like
no the poom boom listen is it like a man
there could be smell i'm telling you
this from first hand experience having
first finger
nappy finger is not when you know it
smells bad you know it's bad
when you're far away and you can smell
it profusely
yes like i've had literal experiences
where i was hitting it from the back and
i had to do the fat joe lean back
because it was so smelly i had to lean
back just so the fumes wouldn't catch me
right ruff i remember this one girl i'm
like damn she's absolutely gorgeous
great personality okay great looks all
right
get to bed boom very enthusiastic yes
yes
she gets god bless i take a whiff okay
and now lean back deuces oh wow
immediately tell the person if i'm just
starting to see you i'm up
if we're in a relationship and it
develops and we have that conversation
with one
right do you tell the person if that
poom poom
people are
[Music]
the reason why i don't tell people is a
selfish reason like i can make it sound
like it's about them but the reality is
i don't like the feeling of having to
tell someone something bad about
themselves
that they're not aware of you know what
i'm saying unless it's like incredibly
toxic in terms of their behavior towards
other people
if it's how they keep their hygiene i
just to me i don't feel comfortable
imposing myself on someone i don't know
them you dig what i'm saying
it doesn't make me feel good yeah so i
just bounce i'm like that's someone
else's responsibility not mine
is it fair no is it the best thing i'll
be honest it's not but i'm not gonna be
the one who says it
that being said i would tell you if i
was dating somebody and they had a
really bad smell they didn't want to
take care of it
i would stop sleeping with them 100 150
for me it's a deal breaker if i'm in a
marriage with a woman and she refuses
and it's i'm not talking about as small
i'm talking about that heavy punch
but you're not supposed to tell women
how they
should feel about their thing it's not
for you to say that abba
okay this person here she has
some stuff that i don't like i i
complain i don't you know what i don't
even i don't even want to know
no no no no you asked you wanted to know
yeah
you can't backtrack now you open that
can take the whoop
yeah hey no i want you guys also to
perceive something that's super
important this conversation
when the man was asked what was the
problem he said i don't want to say
anything it's very private
she was the one who volunteered that
information right he was very private
and respectful about it even though he
had a problem with he's like i'm not
going to air it out to the world
she aired it out and there's another
video of her where she does threaten him
with deportation couple tips wow
and the reason why i wanted to watch
this and bring this up is like imagine
if you reverse these genders
wouldn't you look at the man as
predatory for taking advantage of a
woman in distress
how is this any different it's not how
because here at abbott preach we don't
do the difference it's the same thing
because we're equal
so yeah men do it women do it it's
garbage
don't forget to subscribe to the patreon
it's a huge problem it is a problem if i
saw boss being like if you want to stay
at this job
you have to do this for me this is no
different yo
like i'm telling you so
yeah you saw it a lot i'm not even
working at the bar bro
bro if i go there to get my boogie on
the salsa you know what i mean
you know what i mean i'm gonna have some
fun but you also have to consider the
kind of person that would go to a
foreign country to try to meet someone
or be in a relationship
probably is already operating under the
idea that they're gonna have power over
them
they're probably desperate they're not
good at building relationships
they're going over there to find love to
me that's already very suspect to begin
with
it is suspect right it's already a bad
basis and now you have this person back
here you know you have control over them
it's hard to not want to exert that
because you've already tried to force
control over it by going to a country
where people pay for it most of the time
yeah you know what i'm saying so to me
it's just when i see that happen i'm
pretty sure it's everybody like a lot of
people whenever they see someone
go get a boyfriend one and you're like
[Music]
okay they really go i'm really happy for
you but in the back of my like oh
this could be problematic it can be and
there's a whole bunch of
other couples like this where the woman
threatens the man with deportation a
whole bunch
yeah i've seen men do it i've seen women
do it it's just that
men are not necessarily going to do it
out of the open hmm
why it really looks bad because you know
you can't go like what you're going to
do what you're
you're going to be called right away the
men don't do it openly because they know
how they're going to pay if a man does
it openly it's like yeah whatever
but i've seen a lot of girls do it like
i've seen that
i've seen that so anyways i just want to
bring this up to you guys for today but
we want to hear your thoughts what do
you guys think about this idea is this
predatory
am i imagining stuff we want to hear
your thoughts
uh and that's it
[Music]